good afternoon and welcome to your final
session of day one congratulations so my
name is Rob Crowley and together over
the next hour we are going to attempt to
solve a very pernicious question that's
facing all API developers do we choose
to build our API with rest grat QL or G
or PC and along that journey we're going
to cover quite an amount of topics so
first of all I want to make sure that we
have a common understanding around some
of the terminology that we use so we're
going to take a tour of API Styles over
time so we're going to look at how our
industry's thinking has changed what
they going to look at a little bit of
software architecture and see how we
design systems I'm really taken outside
Ede approach to it so we're gonna look
at architectural constraints and then
the properties or the characteristics
which will then be exhibited by the
systems we build from that we're going
to do it as a bit of myth-busting and
we're going to look at some of the
conversations that are happening in the
API community today and cut through a
little bit of the of the bold statements
I'm a bit more of a new ones to view to
what's happening and then finally with
all of that knowledge we're they going
to look at some sample scenarios and
based on what we've learned or what
we've discussed then look at what an
appropriate technology or a PR style
might be for a problem so before we
proceed a little bit more about myself
so I am a principal consultant at
Telstra purple probably node as ratified
so previous to that I was the technical
lead for api's and authentication at
Bank West so the vast amount of my
career has been in designing operating
and running distributed systems
I'm until recently the last four years
I've been a co-organizer of Dilla T
Perth so WI is the largest IT conference
and I available on socials at Rob D
Crowley so if there's any questions as
you go through this talk either come to
me at the end or just reach out on
Twitter I will be delighted to chat to
you so why am i giving this talk today
well it's kind of self assured I have to
admit it's really reflection on my
Twitter timeline being an absolute tire
fire you see
what I'm really started getting into
api's like wouldn't rest started to
become on vogue about 2010 I started
following all the luminaries in the
industry at that time to my Caymans in
Eric wild and everything was going great
I just took all of their information and
you know where I went and then back in
2015 graph QL came out and of course I
started following a whole new group of
people it turns out that these people
don't agree a lot so yeah I see one
person saying this is amazing and I get
17 tweets re bottle saying no this is
absolutely awful a lot of these
conversations had no nuance at all which
has really left me feeling a little bit
confused so I went away and did a lot of
research to get a more nuanced view on
things so I'll give me one example so
back in 25th of May this year it's my
birthday so I was like yeah it's 2019
why wouldn't we learn grati well so I
retweet this 15 seconds later Aaron
Powell comes back and goes no it's just
fancy Oh data what are you talking about
and well this is a bit of a playful
exchange if you actually go through
Twitter there's actually quite a sir big
exchanges of conversations happening
there was that positive at all and it's
not just on Twitter on blogs as well so
going back to 2017 we've had favorited
dialog of people just saying soap is
absolutely useless we're not gonna use
that anymore all of these api's that we
might have built over a decade not you
don't need them anymore we're all gonna
be building a POS using rest moving
forward and that wasn't just one article
we have another bold claim this rest
rest is now rest in peace so we're not
gonna use rest anymore that's amazing
right and then we're like long live
graph QL so who what does all the
knowledge that we have suddenly got a
waste and didn't you sort of been
thinking history has this sort of
tendency to repeat itself and I'm pretty
sure we've been here before so if that's
the conversation that happened in 2017
let's wind the clock back to 2010 and
now suddenly again we have soap not
gonna need this useless soap is
officially dead Wow say that too like
80% of API is actually running amok
today and again rest is gonna come to
the fore so from those kind of
commentary as well them very much
one-sided views in all these articles so
you probably ponder a couple of things
there so if soap is dead and rest is a
new soap does that mean grad QL is a new
rest yes it's amazing graph QL is indeed
the new rest part would I'm still
waiting for Peres to by the way but in
all of these articles which basically
put forward one technology over another
with very little nuance what are we
going to do is in as an industry do we
just jump ship to the the newest
shiniest thing so what could we have
learned from this well the rooms are
clean maybe we could just say we don't
like XML we move on but there's actually
a deeper problem here
many of our API consumers are just
deeply unhappy or unsatisfied and
frustrated with the choices and the
experience they are providing and this
actually has an important implication so
in the same way that history repeats
itself we've seen back in 2010 when
people were declaring soap is dead and
now it's rest and now 2017 2018 2019
we're having that similar backlash
against rest and everyone's saying graph
QL will come to the ascendency it's fair
to say that if we don't actually tackle
this properly in 2025 there'll be a new
shiny thing and this whole cycle we were
a piece itself again so really one of my
greatest hopes is that we as an API
community are really quite small we
can't afford to take one dimensional
views on one technology or another we
really need to work together and really
be able to grow or collect the knowledge
of a balanced conversations around this
but what we can't do that so what if we
just suddenly said are there all these
different text things that it's it's too
hard
maybe we just throw all of it away and
start again so we could have this world
maybe I'm a dreamer but imagine there's
no protocols no hypermedia Hills to die
on no media types wouldn't that be
amazing would that be a wonderful world
harmony
now it'll be chaos that's not the way
the api's work we need protocols we need
standards it's how we can understand
different sides of the conversation the
same way we need protocols as that is to
drive how information is passed across
the wire we need to understand how we
can talk as a community and have more
fruitful conversations moving forward
otherwise we will be seeing something
else again in 2025 this whole cycle
repeats itself so to gain that empathy
for what's happened before let's
actually look at how api's have evolved
over time and this stuff we've got to go
right back to 1991 with a middleware
called Corbin and back at the time this
was actually gonna be the future of
e-commerce on the web and it was again
an RPC framework so remote procedure
call so a term coined by Bruce Nelson
and it's effectively a way of one system
calling a function in another system as
if that network interface wasn't there
and yes this was absolutely going to be
the future except it fell out of favour
for XML you got forward to 1993 then we
had remote database access so you can
think of this as sequel over the wire so
a way of querying data from a remote
database so again you're probably
thinking query language here and in fact
as we go through this timeline you are
absolutely going to see common thinking
common patterns underpinning most of the
API paradigms that we see and actually
when we talk about some of the new
things like G or PC or graph QL we could
absolutely didn't get an understanding
that these are building on the shoulders
of giants
fast forward to 1998 you have Microsoft
release XML RPC so a specification
around RPC so defining rules for the
exchange so that we can have common
understanding across the parties 1999 we
have done box from Microsoft again one
of the people behind the four tenants of
SOA released soap and this was really
then what gained the ascendancy for
quite a number of
years so it has wisdom again as the
definition language for it at this time
we're just starting to see the tipping
point so we're starting to see some of
those frustrations around heavyweight
protocols as well a new age of lighter
weight web apps being built as well so
in 2000 we're drawing filtering released
a seminal dissertation about a rest so
again building styles that actually
embrace the web and again with this sort
of soap and rest kind of going side by
side with then seeing XML give way to
Jason so in 2005 RPC is still alive and
well but this time instead of XML we
have Jason in 2007 we have OData so very
similar in terms of techniques as to
remote database access all those years
before and it provided a query language
where you can then express it verified
detail what the client requires for a
call and then based on this time I
nothing happened for eight years so in
2015 then we have graph QL released and
an again graph QL very heavily based
towards the client so again the client
being able to express the data that at
once they were receiving it back to one
single call so we give a lot of
similarities to OData and remote
database access before and then most
recently we have the latest incarnation
of RPC framework called G RPC and while
that's the technology view of things
that's actually what looking what's
happening in the industry over that time
so back in 2000 most of the api's we
built were just between two parties so
for a specific partner and they'd be
one-to-one interactions so you will have
asserted me that I need to be able to
talk to you so I will build an API just
for you a lot of things were file
exchanges so EDI that sort of style and
then 2010 with web 2 and ro there was a
massive paradigm change so suddenly
commerce came along and then you're
looking at how can I actually build an
API but have multiple consumers for it
so that's when you would have started to
see Twitter release their API eyes and
that sort of time as well and this is
the second level of generic API so
instead of building for one person we're
trying to satisfy many different people
of many
and needs where we're gonna go next so
if this is very much one-to-one and then
this is one to Manny the next wave will
very much be machine to machine many to
many interactions so complex in network
our last is of calls as well so we
absolutely need to get the automation in
place and have agreement on how we best
own and run these systems moving forward
and I still think we're some way away
from their autonomous future but I think
that's a logical point for what we'll
sort of see over the next three or four
years so across all those technologies
then okay what's the common routing or
techniques underneath them with query
API so graph QL and OData squarely fall
in this area where you would have the
climb being able to define what data you
needed when you still have flat file API
so easy I like extra electronic data
interchange where you might pass a file
between two systems and that's
absolutely fine so maybe payroll updates
at the end of the month where there's
rich sets of data you just need to pass
it from there you don't need it to be
real-time on the other side then you
have streaming API so if you're doing
media or files one has to be absolutely
real-time you can have these other style
of APRs you have our pc so a good gr pc
being an example of that and then web
api so where the predominant amount i
would expect of the api is that we would
build as a group bare so that's where
your rest api is your HTTP endpoint
driven api's would generally fall and
I'm really sorry but there is no
Universal best api style so what are you
thinking I've stayed around until six
o'clock at night just to be told there's
no silver bullet sorry but what I can
say is there is absolutely a best API
style for your problem
so obviously the different styles I've
showed before no one is inherently
better than the other it's really going
to depend on the context of your problem
and really from there we shouldn't be
approaching a problem as I've heard a
lot about graphically well I'd like to
build a graph QL API it's understanding
what fits your particular problem domain
and then being able to decide what is
the simplest way of not only building it
but also operationally moving forward
for your product
what's the cheapest simplest thing that
you can do and to get to the point we
really have to look at the software
architecture side of things so we're
going to look at the properties or
characteristics of the system and that
might be performance scalability of it
the security aspect of it all of those
properties they don't happen by chance
their outputs of the constraints that we
place on the system so for instance rest
has a number of constraints in it so the
uniform interface constraint in that it
says I'm gonna have a consistent
interface or canonical URL into any
particular resource and the property you
would get out of that is simplicity
simplicity from the interface such that
there's a common entry point but
potentially as well that means that the
some loss of efficiency because I've put
an abstraction on top of it so again
it's a trade-off all of these
constraints will mean you get one thing
but you miss out on something else so
they have to be deliberate decisions and
there's many different types of
constraints that we may place in our
system so we might have business
constraints so we might have a customer
and they're only capable of consuming a
file so best of luck to us to try to
give them a rich hypermedia API we could
either maybe convince them to change or
they'll take their business elsewhere we
might have specific product requirements
around how it has to scale how it has to
maybe run from cost of simplicity around
it so these will all be unique to your
particular domain likewise we have
technical constraints so looking at the
a fallacy is distributed computing so
understanding what are the various
interchanges are gonna need to have what
the trade-offs how do I build that
ability for robustus or reliability for
instance between those systems and I
might also gonna be as how likely is it
going to change so do I have a fairly
stable interface or do I need agility to
change through support new features or
potentially a pivot in my startup if I'm
moving forward as well and finally those
interesting ones it's all the human
problems so as to how well do we know
HTTP for instance so if you don't have
an intimate knowledge of HTTP you
probably not setting yourself up for six
to build a REST API for instance because
it's predicated on having very strong
knowledge of that underlying layer as
well because you're building on top of
it you also have to look at how you your
teams are supported around your products
so Conway's law says that the system we
build are always going to mirror the
communication patterns in our
organization so making sure that we've
actually set up our teams around these
API products to give them the best
chance that they're going to be needed
supporters moving forward so once you
have all of these constraints and for
every single system that I rise I write
down all of the constraints and saying
for this particular for this particular
problem which ones do I need to be
concerned with and that would be the mix
of all of these business technical and
socio technical constraints and that
will then yield properties not at the
software system itself but also of the
wider support network around this this
is design right these are all the
decisions around how we choose an
appropriate technology or style for the
problem ahead and then boy fielding
again so the man behind rest says that
it's you're never gonna have a star that
suitable for everything but if you can
compare architectural styles based on
the properties that they're induce it's
way better than just choosing one at
random so this was actually my original
premise for today's talk was to come up
with a framework that would allow you to
navigate that almost like a decision
tree and so it was a little bit
disappointing to find out about ten
minutes into my research that saw was
already dulles a man called den academic
so he gave the keynote as Nordica api's
last year so 2018 and he does a very
good critical review of rest and graph
QL
so rather than rehash a bunch of
material that you can see all the way
but I will include links for everything
at the end as well so no need to take
photos as he going through you will see
the quite detailed approach for how he
methodically ships between the two
paradigms so what are we going to do
instead so it will be a lot more fun I
think to actually look at some of the
conversations that are happening in your
industry and potentially in your own
workplace and then to provide some of
the underpinning principles to be able
to cut through some of the craft or
hyperbole about certain ISO
and then be able to have more balanced
conversations in your own workplace so
if you do what it introduced a new
technology that's going to be perfect
for that problem at hand that you have
enough detail or enough information to
maybe counter some of the the arguments
or points that might be thrown at you so
this look at the first one
so REST API is a rest in peace' api's
long live graph QL or again another
prophet so graph QL will do the rest
what Jason did to XML so again we will
not have to worry about rest moving
forward at all and to do that but we
really have to understand what are these
technologies actually comprise us so as
I mentioned before all of these new
technologies or Styles are underpinned
by things that we've been doing for
decades so in the case of graph QL it's
really about remote database access
glorified wrapped up around the query
side of things so giving the clients the
the power to express their requirements
and then this RPC and on the right side
are the mutation sides so it's really
those two concepts tied together with
some of the learnings from HTTP and
endpoint api's and that's really graph
QL well in a nutshell that's the theory
behind them then if you look at G RPC
it's quite different again so in this
case it's very much about RPC kind of
you give me but it's tied to HTTP 2 so
it makes a specific point around the
transport and it does that because it's
very much focused on performance and
again being able to avail yourself of
many of the features of that underlying
protocol and it uses protobufs for both
the interface definition language like
the schema so if you're thinking of
maybe a REST API
you might be thinking op8 open api
initiative or a pre blueprints or Rabil
or if you're thinking graph QL then that
would be the schema so it still has a
contract involved with it and it uses
that for not just defining it but also
the wire transport as well for the data
format so again quite different and then
suddenly you look at rest and rest is
different again so it's like if graph QL
and G are PCR data over the wire or data
over HTTP rest
very different it's a state machine over
HTTP or a workflow over HTTP and I
should state that we are not actually
tied to HTTP but practically for the
vast majority PI's that we be building
over base this discussion as if we are
talking across those protocol semantics
and just make it clear but what I mean
about state machine is rest does require
hey teos hypermedia as the engine of
application states so we the server will
generate affordances which will then be
processed by the client and I don't want
this statement to be confronting if I
name was feeling a little bit
uncomfortable and I apologize but I
think it's a very important point to
make that a lot of the pain that people
are feeling with REST API was I'm
convinced it's because we actually try
to pick and choose maybe some of the
parents of Roy Fielding's worse that
suit us and when we don't actually
adhere to all the constraints we
actually sacrifice many of the
properties that we would actually
generate in our system so it's just
about understanding when you build a
REST API that what we actually have to
mean I don't actually personally believe
in like a Richardson maturity model
because I don't think it's really
helpful to have level level one level
two it's other rest or it's not and
that's fine I'm not saying that to be
confrontational but I'll explain why
it's a point of moving forward and as I
mentioned I don't really want people to
build kind of rest ish api's I'm firm
firmly convinced that an API where we
loosely hold to some of the properties
would actually be better written in
either an RPC framework or as graph QL
it doesn't mean that everything we do is
to be thrown away it just means that you
will generally get a fair better outcome
for the amount of effort that you would
put it and if you think about all of the
other constraints that I mentioned
before like even a rest assure API still
requires a fair amount of understanding
of HTTP or delight' as well so there's
still quite a barrier to entry to be
able to build one that will evolve scale
over time
and as I mentioned before there is that
one style of API is not any better than
another it's going to be governed by
your context of the problem at hand
so if your API is mostly actions you can
think about the slack API is a great
example of an RPC API then follow on RPC
framework that is absolutely a valid
choice on the other hand if you're
looking at mostly crud or or workflow
over HTTP and manipulating related
resources then rest is a great choice
but again understand your problem at
hand and then work back to the
technology and if you're going to follow
one person on to what I do actually
recommended for surgeon he has a wealth
of information a road API design in
general and a lot of what I'm talking
about though can actually be referenced
in more details in some of the blog's
that he releases and even the creator of
graph QL says it's not perfect in all
scenarios so wonderful for
client-to-server
interactions but for server-to-server he
goes there's probably better options
maybe GRP C or even breast is a better
choice so API Styles they all address
different problem spaces I'm a firm
believer that rest assure a POS would
actually be better written either as
graph QL or RPC and G OPC is perfect for
internal called within your systems well
where performance is absolutely key and
if you want to learn more about your RPC
then I firmly recommend that you go to
Jim Newton's King talk I believe at 9
o'clock and room 3 tomorrow but do
confirm the schedule because a bicep
changes I checked
what's another sort of myth that gets
perpetuated one of my favorites is graph
QL breaks caching full stop just breaks
it and this is one staple it has
absolutely no context at all first of
all we should be asking what kind of
caching do we mean client-side caching
so that might be in the browser or you
hate you to be cloned or do we mean
server-side caching or is it Network
ation so in between the client and the
server so there's many different kinds
so if we look at HTTP based casing
yes we can absolutely do it other client
or the server side often called
application casing but we can also use
intermediary proxies like squid or
varnish to hold that data close to the
client as well so shared cases with
graph QL and G RPC we don't have these
intermediary cases so graph QL does tree
HTTP as a dumb pipe and mainly uses
posts which will be cached across the
wire but we can still absolutely use
either a denormalized client case or
case you or the server side so we really
have to talk about what kind of caching
but why our intermediary proxies
important because while the speed of
light is fast 300,000 kilometers per
second closer equals faster so if you
can get your data cached close to your
clients it's the whole edge computing
proxy case as well it will typically get
to the client faster and we can improve
things a little bit with graph QL
whereby you can use persistent queries
with a guess to allow you to actually
issue queries with a verb that will be
cached by the client but it's not
supported by absolutely all service so
if you're in the node ecosystem so
Apollo at Apollo server supports this
quite nicely and this is really a
reflection of graph QL being in its
infancy so in comparison to rest which
has been a rich history of problems
being solved in the ecosystem over 10
years graph you all are still quite
young so there's still quite an amount
of bike shedding around certain topics
which have actually been solved in the
rest space previously however there is
another point to consider here so
authenticated traffic so any traffic
that has an authorization header so if
you've logged into a site that will
typically not be cached by intermediary
proxies so if you were dealing with
personalized data a lot of this argument
might not be applicable for you at all
so if we were building a real-time API
where the data changes quite a lot and
all of the data is behind or tied to
what identity thing you don't really
lose anything from
he well with this caching story so again
just understand not only the problem the
technology but also what type of days
are how quickly would have changed these
are all things that could drive your
choices and while it might be an issue
in one side might absolutely not be a
problem for you at all
the other point to consider is the fact
that the more customizable an API is so
the more power that you grant a client
to request what the data that it
requires the less capable or the lower
hit rate you will get for those
resources make sense so if I if I have
an API and the only thing you do is
slash users slash one what slash users
slash - then yes there's very low
variability that requests so you could
have a high hit rate but if you think
about how graph QL is defined it gives
all the power to the client to define
what data it needs so even if you can
cache it you probably won't get very
high hit rate on that in any case so the
key takeaway the more customizable you
you get you you're making your API
probably the less value you will get
from the casing side at least of that
intermediary store so casing many
different kinds of cases client-server
networking understand which ones are
suitable for your problem highly
customizable API is benefit let's from
HTTP caching if your data is mainly
static and not personalized then rest is
a great choice because you can leverage
the network ation and best practices are
still absolutely emerging in the G RPC
and grotty well spaces this is another
one that gets thrown around a lot REST
API czar inefficient but rest was never
about efficiency if you look at what
Roy's fielding was talking about many of
the constraints which he put in place
are actively against short-term
efficiency and rather it's about log
Germany so API is world wide web that
will continue to evolve over decades and
allow the client and the server to
evolve independently so that's really
where rest is going but when we say
inefficient in many cases the
conversation is actually about
performance
so the chattiness can you actually
deliver
that client experienced with the speed
and typically a problem that gets thrown
at rest api is is that about over or
under fetching so do you either retrieve
too much data and send that back to the
client at the risk of using too much of
their data pled or limited bandwidth or
do you retrieve too little data forcing
them to do many round trips so often
known as the m+ one problem but there
are techniques for this so spacefield
sets where the client can say I only
want this field this field in this field
is absolutely a valid approach as well
so while graph QL has a really strong
story in this area it is nothing that we
couldn't do with rest with a little
effort and then under fetching what our
typical response there in the HTTP 1
world was to use compound documents so
instead of just retrieving one resource
or one representation at a time combined
mani and that's actually the underlying
principle in json api or how's the
hypermedia application language where it
gives us a common vocabulary or syntax
for embedding or creating compound
documents the graph QL story is amazing
because the client can express exactly
what they want we can get all the data
no more no less than exactly one round
trip to the server it sounds absolutely
wonderful in fact what graph QL came out
this was really proportion to be one of
its major benefits but as always there's
a trade-off to this so by retrieving all
of this data in a single call we have
now bound the response to the client to
the slowest piece of data on the server
so if there are expensive fields that
are your computing on the server side
the client will get no data until such
time as that field has resolved as well
so there's always a trade-off in terms
of the numbers of calls and the
experience you want to provide and so
the graphical community looked at many
ways that could overcome this so again
Apollo led led the way with deferred
queries where we could we could send
back the initial response and then we
could annotate certain parts of our
queries with defer which means that when
it actually becomes available on the
server we could then send a patch to the
client as part of a multi-part HTTP
response and then over time the client
will
to get all the data until such time as
it has the entire object graph but
shouldn't really be this complicated
you just like we're just adding
complexity over complexity and what
we're really looking to get around in
this case is HTTP 1 where the cost of a
handshake both at the TCP and TLS level
is expensive and in fact reusing
connections then consistently becomes a
trade-off between how many how many
resources do I use to actually create a
number of pooled requests versus again
the handshake and the time for all of
that handshake and content window sizing
to actually scale so it's really about
network hacks so HTTP 2 absolutely
solved this at the protocol level at
layer 7 where we can now have multiple
multiplex streams on a single connection
in HTTP 2 we still have head-of-line
blocking asked the layer for level so
TCP but upcoming will have HT to be 3
which will solve it at that level as
well by using UDP so if anyone's
followed quick or any of the
documentation from Google around that so
in the same way the speedy became HTTP 2
will have quick becoming HTTP 3 so that
will allow us gain a lot more efficiency
in sending representations across the
wire but also comes with another feature
so server push so imagine again if we
had a hyper media driven API where you
get a root level resource and then
afterwards you get all the children so
the server in that case could say oh if
you ask for the root level resource then
maybe I'll just push the children to you
so in fact when the client that looks to
a tree that it's already in their case
so instead of request response the
server can then say I will actually push
prematurely those resources back to the
users as well how well this has been
available from 2015 the fact is primary
use case was in the browser to load CSS
and JavaScript for the browser they
actually found the prefetch links were
actually more effective for that regard
but there's a lot of talk in the API
community though about this big a
potential kind of like perfect use case
for some of the endpoint driven API is
allowing for finer grained resources
rather than the large chatty copper
documents we had before while still
getting patient
so around performance page top-1 was
really the root cause for all of these
compound documents and in fact one of
the first selling points of graph QL so
http/2 removes much of the need for
compound documents so we could liberate
ourselves from creating sort of large or
potentially over fetching data and
server push does have a huge amount of
potential for changing pieces or
changing the way that we actually
deliver content to the client but it's
not quite there yet so there has been a
library released this week called
volcano that actually promotes that use
of a client saying I would like these
additional resources along with the
route one and then being able to push
that data to the cloud but profile use
cases carefully and in fact people are
so bullish about server push that I was
saying HTTP to mix graphic you all
absolutely irrelevant and this is just
stuff I added today because there's
actually been a lot of content this week
about how much server push will change
the API landscape but just to call out
that graph QL is not just about network
efficiency this pheromone is shaving a
few bytes across the wire graph QL or
the value that it provides is really the
sum of its parts so again the schema is
fantastic but yes you could actually
achieve this through open API initiative
introspection is amazing you can
approximate that with hypermedia so
there's nothing really revolutionary
around graph QL but it's really all of
those different parts and taking a
developer focus on it that reading that
adds that incredible intuitive and a low
effort to get started with it and if you
really look at what developer experience
then is it's really about the docs that
you can provide to your users so
understanding the shape and contract of
your API and then SDKs or client
libraries for how you can consume it and
you can get both of those right which
graph QL does incredibly well then that
can lead people being able to consume
your API there's a rich ecosystem of
tooling around as well so code
generation like type graph QL to
generate all of your typescript types
off the schema as well it's just a
beautiful ecosystem so when people say
about graph QL or it's just about
efficient network transfer it's actually
everything else over the above it that
really makes it so special
so the true value of graph QL it lies in
the tooling and the developer experience
that it provides then again though if
you're only concerned with network
efficiency then hate should be to
endpoint may be a great choice moving
forward but this story will evolve and
will continue to change over time so in
the 1 so graph QL eliminates the need
for versioning you don't have to do it
anymore
but we never actually had to do
versioning it was a strategy not a
requirement and it was a strategy to
allow clients to evolve ask different
rates and to dealing with breaking
changes in the API contract but there's
other ways of tackling this problem as
well
so instead of versioning you can look at
gracefully evolution which really
underpins the the concept of rest as
well so when Roy fielding was asked how
should you virgin version a REST API he
was like don't it wasn't a great
interview but like was graph QL has
taken the same point it doesn't support
versioning either so really both of
these want us to look at this graceful
evolution style and again from building
api's over time supporting multiple
versions is actually quite an expensive
case as well so it's really not in the
providers or producers site is about
multiple api's at the same time so
wherever possible if we can achieve it
with gracefully evolution then we should
but it requires discipline it means we
can't add new required inputs we can't
remove outputs or make them optional
because people might rely on them we
can't change the type of a field so
before was a number we can change it to
a string because there's expectations
around this and we really have to follow
the robustness principle apostle's law
about only caring about the data that we
want and not breaking if something else
changes that we haven't expressed an
interest in and the key point here is
you cannot over communicate with your
users so if you are going to introduce a
change send the newsletter don't just
rely on at application or at sunset
heather's on your response creators open
a dialogue as you can give them a period
to say this has been deprecated and we
will sunset it in three months time
allow them time to to move it so it
doesn't mean you can't do breaking
changes but having communication between
those is absolutely key if however you
have a client and you have no influence
over their ability or race to change
then yes version might be a prudent
choice there but only only if you can't
exert any control or influence over your
clients adults that there would be my
recommendation and this isn't just about
the server it's also on a client side so
being a tolerant reader so if the server
decides to change the order of fields
and the responses don't break if they
add additional fields that you didn't
expect
don't break I don't do like
serialization directly into a class so
really only look at the data that you
would it depended of order so again it's
about being well-behaved citizens of
both sides of the network and if you
want to learn more about that is defined
as an integration pattern by Merritt and
Fowler as well so he has a lot of great
information about building robust
integrations between systems and graph
QL has a great story to tell in this
case as well so both deprecations so
again we can master compared to the
schemas be at deprecated and in any of
the Doc's that the client sees the
condense see that this fields has been
deprecated and also you know exactly
what fields every user is using so you
know who to talk to so that's very
powerful in that case so graph QL does
make it easier to manage grocery
evolution but it is absolutely possible
with other techniques as well an
interesting observation that we should
make here though as well is that if an
API has a sufficient number of consumers
chances are that someone's going to use
every pairs of your API so really
understanding who uses what is actually
not that valuable because everything
will be used by someone and so then if
we are making a certain change you can
also say it's not just about the schema
of it but people might have a reliance
on certain
other behaviors of it so either like the
speed or time or a number of other
non-functional aspects as well so if you
ever changing an API or looking at
migrating it we often have this point we
often have this case of like bug for bug
compatibility so someone will depend on
behavior of the API even if you see is
it just fix your error
it might actually be a breaking change
for what are your clients as well so
again there is absolutely no substitute
for keeping that lines of communication
open we can get the most value from
systems than by defining at that
interface so while I was talking a
little bit about implicit behavior
before the best leverage that we can
have for our systems is by the
interfaces of contracts that we create
so I would always advocate for a
contracts first approach irrespective of
the style that you have so in rest that
can be open API initiative a pre ramble
any one of those things would start with
this design start with a conversation
and then work from there
and what might a contract for us flow
look like so it might be in G RPC that
the protocol buffer file itself or would
graft you all the schema after that's
been agreed you can have the client and
the API be developed in parallel
potentially by different teams and then
finally integrated into a product at the
end of the whole loop continues again
but having that defined behavior in the
mill is incredibly powerful and that's
where you look at all of these styles of
rich ecosystems to allow other the
mocking of data throwing development as
well
so versioning it is just a technique for
managing breaking changes it is not a
requirement it should be a last resort
really prefer gracefully evolution and
only if you can not exert control over a
client to change then look at versioning
absolutely not a substitute for
communication with users and it also
doesn't protect a user from requiring a
persistent piece of behavior from the
API that maybe it wasn't intended before
but has now become part of the flow so
always keep the lines of communication
open so
domaine modeling is only a concern for
rest so if you're building a graph you
LAPI don't worry it will all be good
that's not really the case is it so
irrespective of the style that we have
you have to understand the API uses
needs so you always have to start with
the users in mind and this is where you
really start with the contract as well
so if you have a user maybe another team
in your company or maybe if it's
external try to have that design
happening as fluently as possible at the
start but there is absolutely no escape
so if you're building graphically well
on top of a suite of existing restful
services graph QL will give you one new
chance to build the API you wish you
would built the first time but after
that you're into managing changes at
deprecations and updates as well so
incredibly important that design
irrespective of what we're looking at
and the interesting thing what rest is
at rest we actually always start by
defining the endpoints so we have to
start with how our users are going to
consume this data graph QL starts a
little bit differently in terms of we
actually start defining the schema first
and how those various types relate to
each other and then from there the user
will express an interest in a certain
subset of that graph so graph QL allows
us to delay the responsibility for
identifying user needs until we actually
start profiling queries so from that
regard if you are a little uncertain
about your users needs for a particular
API or you are looking to support
multiple different clients say mobile
wearables or desktop than each of very
different data needs then graph QL
allows you to support multiple use cases
in a single API again but the payoff for
that or rather the downside is graph QL
API is a far more complicated to operate
and performance tuning can be a lot more
onerous with them as well so again
always looking at what's the simplest
thing that you could do so API design
there are no free dinners it is
absolutely table stakes irrespective of
the style that you have so designing a
restful api follows outs
the inflow so you start with the users
start defining your endpoints how
they're gonna consume the data and then
work back in and then graph QL allows us
to delay the moment profile in queries
so again it allows us to deal with
uncertainty a little bit more elegantly
right so looking at all that sort of
information before so we've talked about
a lot of pros and cons of different
styles as well we're now over the next
sort of ten minutes or so gonna look at
a couple of sample scenarios and then
from there hopefully have about five six
minutes to discuss them in questions
afterwards so taking our principle of
choosing the absolute simplest thing
possible for a given use case so if I'm
building a form simpler web form maybe
registering for an event and it's just
crud maybe it's a single client then
simply the simplest thing you can do is
a crud rest interface like if you look
at where graph QL comes from it's about
retrieving many different shapes of data
and doing that efficiently if that's not
a concern then it's not going to be the
right fit for you which might be shame
because you might go I really want to
build one of those api's but choose the
simplest thing possible however a use
case where graph your shines is a
composite API so previously you might
have Europe sba and it's been calling
multiple different API is that it has to
do all that logic to stitch that data
together potentially has to deal with if
one of those calls fail does it retry
all of that logic that was pushed to the
client graphic UL can absolutely shine
here as an extension or a BFF so
actually changing that boundary between
the clients of the server I'm putting a
lot of that control over the server to
then aggregate their days I'd just pass
exactly the data that the client needs
so that's incredibly powerful as well so
if you have multiple different clients
you need to support then graphically
well can be an absolutely phenomenal
chad's or choice for that and if you
want a bit more detail about how you
might go about building a composite API
I've included a link at the end to the
talk I gave it at DC last year which
actually goes into actually building a
server and react Clyde in a lot more
detail but at a high level that's
effectively what
look like so it is absolutely not tied
to having a REST API underneath it but
it could be an e michael service even
talking g RPC could be directly to a
database so graph QL does not care about
the underlying data source
it is about querying the data that he
needs expressed against the schema but
that's about web then what about maybe a
native mobile app and again it's gonna
be in the control so it'd be FF so in
control of that one product team so
again maybe a single client and the API
is static and well-understood so maybe
we know the shape of data it's not going
to change a lot so maybe a lot of those
things I spoke about before what graph
you will be able to delay that point
where we have to think about the user
needs and from there I'm actually really
excited about G RPC in these cases as
well so typically we've looked at us for
just the the communication between micro
services maybe within a bounded context
you can absolutely see it then becoming
more pervasive across the stack as well
and obviously this comes with quite a
those for you as well that you can have
a single protocol end-to-end across your
stack as well there are absolutely some
issues with this as well with supports
for HTTP to odd applications herbs as
well but the story is improving all the
time and also the fact with G RPC being
able to have a single protocol foe and
then be able to generate clients and
service stubs in multiple different
languages is incredibly appealing as
well so and so if you can standardize
your road times within your organization
and teams are writing maybe some in Java
someone Ross maybe sub in JavaScript
they're having G RPC being able to
fulfill client libraries in each one of
those libraries and then maybe your host
all your services in Dhaka that can be a
beautiful pattern as well but don't
constrain your thinking should just
inter-service communication and again so
that's a really nice kind of traditional
pattern I'm sure this is something that
James Newton King will touch on in this
talk but for a dot there core three
perspective one thing that might
actually quite surprised you is g-o-p
see in the web so there is another
project as part of that ecosystem that
now says how do we do it from the
browser it's not just about mobile apps
and that's actually achieved via running
a do PC proxy so browsers themselves
don't can't be just tied to HTTP two
they can always behavior to be one
traffic as well so if you can to make
the chrome debugger you can actually see
what be passed across the wire so what
that does is convert between the
potential HTTP 1x traffic and that allow
it to flow into HTTP 2 on the back end
and again I expect this story would
improve over time but if you're keen to
have consistency and protocol end-to-end
then that can be quite appealing so what
did we cover in this talk so at the very
start we looked at a lot of the
dialogues or questions that's happening
in the API communities today we've seen
that there's very little nuance in those
conversations so we looked at some of
the architectural styles over time and
what we've really seen is that the same
ideas have been coming up or arising
time after time just with the different
badges of different technical names
around them we then looked at two design
systems we really have to think about
the behavior that we want from the
system and actually work back to say
what are the constraints or what are the
invariants that we can apply during
design time that will yield those
characteristics and again we need to be
deliberate about this we then took a
quick walled world through all of the
conversations that are happening in the
team arena my goal from that is to give
you that level of detail such as if
those conversations or similar ones are
arising in your organization that you
can start asking the right questions are
raising the right points to be able to
get to a good outcome moving forward
then at the very end we looked at a
couple of examples so really what my
goal from there is not to give you an
exhaustive list of use cases and
patterns there was a huge amount of
material out there but rather get you
thinking about one of the systems that
I'm designing with this information
would I do something slightly different
or is it just confirmation yes I've made
the right choice but it's about making
more informed choices moving forward so
it's been an absolute pleasure to talk
to you this afternoon I hope you enjoy
this as I hope to see somebody with the
boat cruise thank you
[Applause]